so you're in the juvenile facility
you're 17 but then you turn 18 you go to
kenosha county jail actually i go to
kenosha county jail as i turn as i'm 17.
i'm in adult jail
at october 31st i'm extradited which i
agree with i wanted to go to kenosha
county jail from the beginning
i was extradited
to kenosha county jail
my attorney john pierce said oh we're
going to keep you in a
juvenile facility i always want to be
extradited
and i had no problem with that but he
forgot to
file the saying he didn't even know i
was going
um so my attorney didn't know i was
going to jail which is quite sickening
because he should have known
well yeah the whole point of an attorney
yeah right
thank god i have confident counsel now
yeah um
but
the jail was interesting i was in my own
room it was kind of like a
like a once i'm gonna describe it as a
one-star hotel
a one-star hotel we'll go with a super
eight super eight i had a desk i had a
shower i had a toilet i had a tv
i had a tablet
um
but i didn't have running water
seriously
i had a phone also but i did not have
running water so i didn't shower until
november 20th
from october 31st to november 20th i did
not take a shower that's disgusting a
very um i smelled terrible i felt sick i
lost a weight my health was degrading
if i was in there for enough a month
longer i would probably been in a
hospital wait
you had no running water no running
water in my jail cell
did you do they let you out
to talk with my attorneys i didn't
really say anything about my running
water because i'm not i don't like to
bring attention to myself i don't want
to draw any problems with any of the
guards
so i was like i'm just gonna i'm just
gonna shut up and not mention that i
don't have running water
um but i didn't shower for until
november 20th and when i showered my i
showered for like i took like a three
hour shower
i had like blood my skin was bleeding
because
my skin was coming off of my body it was
just the nastiest thing ever
and i feel bad for dave who's been with
me through the beginning who's helped
start free kyle usa.org
i feel bad for him because he had to
deal with my smell for that three hour
car ride so i give him all the credit in
the world
imagine putting that kid in jail one of
the very few people in downtown kenosha
that night who was there for the right
reasons who was trying to help who was
trying to bring order out of disorder
was trying to protect rather than
destroy
and they put him in jail and the most
infuriating part is the facts haven't
changed videotape of that night was
available almost immediately to anyone
who wanted to see it it was very clear
this man had acted this boy had acted in
self-defense and they locked him up
anyway because of political pressure hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else